I've been using my lg ultra find 5k
display since it launched over four
years ago and overall I've been
extremely happy with it but it does have
a few missing features that I really
wanted thankfully after so many years of
people complaining Apple finally made
another display the 6k Pro display XDR
so today I'll be doing a detailed
comparison of these high resolution
displays helping you decide which one is
better for your needs because once you
get all the info it's actually a pretty
easy choice
now you might expect me to tell you that
if you have the money then just buy the
XDR and if not then get the LG 5k but
that's not true at all there are
actually three specific areas that the
LG ultrafine 5k display beats out the
pro display XDR and no that doesn't
include the massive price difference or
the included stand but I'll touch on
that anyways the LG 5k comes in at $1300
compared to five thousand for six
thousand dollars for the XDR so the
price difference is massive and that's
without the stand you can actually buy a
refurbish LG 5k for $100 less than the
pro stand by itself so if you want to
score a great deal I'll go ahead and
leave a link to that down in the video
description now as far as the build
quality of the stands themselves there
is no comparison the pro stand by itself
gets close to the full weights of the LG
5k and it is extremely stable the LG
stand is mostly mad at a plastic with a
solid metal base but that's still not
enough to keep it from wobbling both
stands have a fairly similar amount of
adjustability but only the pro stand can
go vertical the pro stand is easier to
adjust but it does have a downside the
distance from the wall will change while
you're adjusting it so if you have a
small desk it could end up feeling a bit
too close to you the prost and attaches
instantly using ultra strong magnets
whereas the LG 5k uses a mechanical
spring lock which is also very quick to
attach compared to other monitors
beneath the locking plate the LG 5k
hides a vase amount if you want to ditch
the wobbly stand completely but on the
pro display xcr you have to buy a $200
base amount adaptor separately another
thing we see on the LG 5k is a tiny fan
that helps keep the display cool whereas
the XDR is fanless thanks to us unique
passive cooling design that's built into
the aluminum frame the LG 5k also has a
lock built-in was she don't get on the
XD are they both have one Thunderbolt 3
input and 3 USB type-c ports offering
USB 3.0 connections however there is a
caveat with the pro Display XD are the
ports on the back of the LG 5k display
support those speeds using any Mac so
our external SSD can run close to 400
megabytes a second however with the XDR
it has to be plugged into a Mac with
AMD's latest nabi based graphics like
the 16 inch macbook pro any Mac without
Navi graphics like the 15-inch MacBook
Pro or even the brand new Mac Pro with
the $2400 Vega 2 graphics option doesn't
support the latest display stream
compression technology so running the 6k
display XDR uses up all of the available
bandwidth leaving none of it left over
for the USB ports on the back of the
display so those ports end up running at
USB 2.0 speeds which means we get about
40 megabytes per second speeds even with
our super fast SSD basically making the
ports useless for anything other than
basic accessories when we plug this SSD
into the Mac Pro itself we can get
speeds of about 800 megabytes per second
instead of 40 fortunately Apple will
soon be selling the Navi based W 50 700
X graphics card for the Mac Pro which
will allow those ports to run at the
full USB 3.0 speeds now before I tell
you two other areas where the XDR lacks
I want to say thanks to our sponsor
Micro Center for making our pro xzr
content possible Micro Center has 25
stores nationwide with an impressive
variety of electronics from gaming VR
computer parts like processors graphics
and everything else needed to build or
upgrade a PC or Mac Micro Center has
been an Apple authorized dealer since
1980 they have a dedicated Apple
Department with highly trained Apple
sales associates aside from the iPhone
Microsoft Ares the full lineup of Apple
products and they have the largest
selection of third-party products made
for Mac and iPad come into a local Micro
Center today and talk to one of their
Apple experts to order the specific Mac
Pro that fits your needs or a pro
display XDR you can also check the link
in the video description to find a
location near you or to browse all of
Apple products before I get into how
amazing the pro x-ers panel is I want to
talk about the build quality differences
the LG uses average quality plastic all
around compared to an all-aluminum
design that looks and feels very premium
the lattice pattern cutouts allow for
not only better airflow but it reduces
weight while retaining strength on the
front side the entire panel is glass
with bezels that are impressively thin
for the size of the display especially
when you compare it to the 5k LG display
which has a large plastic protruding
frame all the way around one nice thing
about the ultrafine 5k is that it comes
with a microphone and a 1080p webcam
hidden in the bezel and it actually
looks quite decent the pro display xzr
completely lacks a webcam but Apple does
sell a 4k Pro magnetic webcam for $200
on their website but it is currently
sold out and backordered for about two
months so it shows how much people
actually care about having a webcam with
their display to me this isn't a big
deal but what I do care about our
speakers the LG 5k comes with built-in
speakers which don't sound the best but
they do get quite loud and I would use
them for basic tasks and then when I
needed some really good quality sound
out switch to good headphones
since the XDR doesn't come with built-in
speakers you have to buy external ones I
got these ones here which sound way
better than the built-in LG's so much of
course that makes sense and I'll just go
ahead and link those for you guys down
in the video description if you're
interested now let's get into what makes
this display worth that $6,000 price tag
the image quality and I would actually
argue way more than $6,000 yes it is
6-game meaning it has just over 20
million pixels whereas the LG 5k has a
little bit under 15 million now that may
sound like you're getting a lot more
detail but since the display itself is a
larger 32 inches compared to 27 inches
you're still getting the same 218 pixels
per inch which Apple considers red and
equality both look extremely good and at
normal viewing distances you can't see
the pixels unlike a 4k display that's
about as large as these two the LG 5k
display can output a really solid 500
nits of brightness but it's not enough
for Apple to consider HDR capable even
though a lot of other brands mark
there is displays a supporting HDR which
some of them actually have brightness as
low as 315 it's the pro display XDR on
the other hand can sustain a massive
1000 nits of brightness across the
entire display at the same time and up
to a shocking 1600 nits in certain areas
of the screen when working with HDR
content however when you're not viewing
or working with HDR both the LG 5k and
the pro display XDR will max out at
around 500 nits since you don't really
need the extra brightness this is one
area I wish Apple gave us more room to
play with on the xcr display both
displays have some brightness shift when
viewing at extreme angles and there also
is some color shift but the LG 5k is
much worse as you can see by the white
balance while the XDR stays very similar
reflectivity is fairly similar unless
you buy the nano-coated XDR for $1,000
more which pretty much eliminates
reflections while maintaining colors and
sharpness which is an amazing
achievement by Apple one absolutely huge
and massive difference is contrast the
LG's contrast looks good in bright rooms
just like the 5k iMac and Mac books but
the XDR puts it to shame if you care
about sustained brightness the very best
Oh LEDs get dramatically dimmer and most
can only output about 300 nits with half
of the display at full brightness and
even less than that for the full screen
whereas the X er can sustain the full
screen at 1000 nits those displays are
totally fine for watching HDR content
since a lot of the time you won't have
the full screen brightness set that high
but when you're editing HDR that is a
huge limitation LCDs like the LG 5k
don't have that issue but they really
lack contrast so instead of the one
backlight that's in the LG 5k Apple has
created a massive 576 back lights to get
the very best of both worlds there is
one downside with the XDR compared to
OLED and that is blooming but it is only
visible in extreme unrealistic scenarios
like here where I really just max out
the brightness in a totally dark room
and I found text which was ultra bright
with you know black in between the
letters
and here you notice that it starts
turning gray but if we take a look at
the LG 5k the whole display is basically
great if you turn the brightness down a
bit it does go away and in rooms like
this you would never have it above maybe
25 or 30 percent brightness if you want
the ability to accurately edit HDR which
is the main reason we bought our display
you have to go with the XDR the other
reason for it is color accuracy both the
5k and the XDR comes standard with DCI
p3 color accuracy but the pro display
comes factory calibrated with a full set
of reference modes so you can work in
the color space you need which is great
for high-end pro work on top of that the
XDR is a true 10-bit color display
meaning it could display over 1 billion
colors instead of 16.8 million on the LG
5k which is truly an 8-bit panel if
you're somebody that needs to edit HDR
content or have a true 10-foot display
with reference modes then the XDR is a
choice for you for most people though
the XDR is overkill and the LG 5k is
just a sharp with good color accuracy
and brightness yes it does like HDR but
most people don't need that in a display
and although the contrast isn't as
jaw-dropping in normal lighting
conditions it does look just as good as
other IMAX and MacBook Pros you also
have the comedian PSA's of the built-in
speakers the mic the webcam all for a
fraction of the price of course if you
have the money and you want the very
best display that you can get for your
Mac one that supports HDR with amazing
colors and contrast then you know look
into getting an XDR display it is
absolutely amazing especially when you
see it in person alright guys let me
know if you have any questions or
comments down below and go ahead and
click up there on the circle if you guys
want to see our detailed review of this
XDR display with a lot more info there's
been max and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]